hi everyone it's jerry
let's have a look at a game that was
played on july 3rd 2021
so it was played just a few days ago at
leaches.org
blitz titled arena this was
a three hour event of three minute chess
an event i normally would have liked
to cover on twitch
but i was unable to make that happen and
i really picked a good one to miss out
on
said sarcastically of course carlson had
a remarkable
performance he ended up setting three
records
the game i'm about to share with you was
his
30th consecutive win that's how he
started the event
30 wins in a row that was a record
so too was his 94 percent win rate
in the event and
the rating he achieved after winning
this game right here
set a highest blitz rating ever on
leaches.org
what's the number 3136
wrap your head around that figure it's a
big one um
feel free to share what your highest
blitz rating
is uh that's a
that's a remarkable number uh
so let's dive in here and see how he got
to 3136
first of all who's who carlson's playing
the white pieces under the account
and dr nichterstein his opponent
grand master alexa 81
who's that we don't know they're an
anonymous grand master
something i can share however about
elixir 81 is that
they're a fantastic blitz player i say
this from
first hand experience i've had the
opportunity to play against alexa 81
about a few dozen times
and well their high blitz rating of 2955
speaks for itself okay what's happening
in this game
not a whole lot fairly
non-confrontational
minimal tension in the early going some
pressure on the night
big deal these last two moves by white
knight to d2
rook e1 are doing what preparing
a pawn break so that the rooks can
finally see the world
see the enemy's side of the board it's
important for black to eliminate this
pawn
if it's allowed to go to e5 it's too
valuable for white
eliminating uh taking over control of f6
is disruptive of course to the knight
and maybe the bishop
and other knight who may want to make
use of that square as well one day
okay it's got to go so captures away on
e4
and if you look at the stockfish
evaluation it's going to
basically always tip in white's favor
somewhat
from this position and i believe it's
primarily looking at
the imbalance in the center white has a
fourth ranked pawn black has a third
rank
okay nothing substantial though for
either side
nothing substantial for white queens are
now in tension
with this last move white is also now
out of a pin
and so the knight is ready to jump in
and improve on e5
with a punch and maybe begin to start to
intersect
some on the e6 and f7 structures we
could start drawing some lines
and this this structure can maybe start
to become a bit
sensitive and vulnerable to tactics
right
wherever there are intersections just
like cars
accidents are nearby okay
this is a blitz game quick decisions are
made black doesn't want to even
cope with the knight on e5 and says i'll
give you the bishop pair
show me how you break down my position
okay
rook d8 small improvement with king to
g2
black initiates the exchange white is
ever so slightly helped
because of that decision it's nice to
have the rook on the half open file
the fact that white has doubled b pawns
should not be seen as a liability
for white it remains super solid
nice and compact for white without
serious weakness
a6 h4
i've kind of skimmed through these first
17 moves it's a 40 move game but this is
the moment i'd like to draw
attention to
this next decision but next decision by
black is important
and i'd like to throw first of all a pop
quiz your way
uh let's say you're playing as black
what move would you play here
feel free to pause the video okay
the move played in the game is knight to
d5
now what i'm about to say next is
going to sound really ridiculous super
bold
but i'll do it anyway i think that
knight to d5 is
a losing move now if you stare at your
favorite chess engine
you're going to see numbers that
basically say jerry you're ridiculous
it's not winning for white and i get
that i realize that
you know that's somewhat of an
exaggeration but let me share some of my
thoughts here
first of all you know this event again
is something that i normally would have
uh
covered live on twitch and i'd upload
the whole three hours
to youtube i didn't get a chance to do
that so i thought to myself
you know let's at least check out one of
his games
one of the games i was drawn to of
course was the 30th game
the one that set the record i thought to
myself that'd be fun
let's just see how he got the record you
know 3136
awesome but to my surprise i actually
ended up walking away from this game
learning a thing or two
i didn't really expect that i
you know it's just a blitz game what can
you really pull away from a blitz game
alright what can i add to this position
i'd like to
i'd like to focus on this moment here i
think this is a super instructional
moment here
and uh one that you can improve you you
could be an improved chess player from
so here we go uh i believe
that allowing white to position his pawn
in h5
which was white's reply here will enable
white
to create a desirable pawn
break on the king's side a pawn break
that will
extend the scope of his rooks in a
favorable way
now i know that that's a mouthful but
let me let me be a little bit more
uh precise here let me let me point out
some additional things
uh first of all the rooks the white
rooks
if you just look at them quickly you'll
see some may say to
themselves they're doing they're doing
they're on half open files they're
they're working
they're not working that's not good
enough
in this position type there are rooks in
this position
uh three half open files let's look at
them
what do they all have in common let's
look at the points they're observing
what do these three points all have in
common
what's something we can say well they're
all
rock solid they're secure they're
watched over by a pawn
neither side is inconvenienced by the
fact that these rooks are on half open
files and
putting pressure on these pawns they're
solid
an additional pawn break must surface
in order for the rook's presence to
truly be felt in this position
once one side can bring it to a point
where
a rook is exerting pressure on a pawn
and let's say that pawn
needs the support of a piece
not a pawn then there's now an
inconvenience
in the position there's a defender
that cannot do some other stuff
let's say so a pawn break is necessary
is what i'm getting at
and it is extremely important in my
opinion
that black not make the move knight to
d5 but rather
h5 i believe that it is
super important to have this ram
structure these two instances of fixed
pawns
pawn on h4 black pawn on h5
if it's allowed where white has upon an
h5
versus the pawn on h6 this difference
matters this means that white will be
able to
push forward on the king side
and not create any serious
weaknesses along the way what do i mean
by this well let me just say
that after these moves are played after
we get to this position right here
what white ends up playing is bishop to
d1 what's what's the idea there
it's just a get out of the way type of
move a clearance move
the f pawn needs to contribute this guy
needs to go here
this guy needs to go here and then white
is what
a step away from creating a pawn break
on the king side with maybe
f5 or g5
now if we go back
and try this same method of advancing
the f
pawn when there's this guy here
let's say this and let's say this is
played
and now we have this plan f4
not the same not the same why
g4 as a whole look at the grip black
would have over the g4 square
it is in short not so clear
how white breaks down how white would
create a successful pawn break on the
king side
if there's a black pawn on h5 the fact
that black
allows a white pawn on h5 well we're
going to see
a nice pawn roller surface now on the
king side for white
black doesn't want to see this pawn get
any further by the way
getting it h6 will be disruptive as well
so okay h6 by black b4
and king to f8 you know i was saying
just a little bit ago
it's a losing move that knight to d5
move okay
i get that that's somewhat of an
exaggeration i think something you
you may find it a bit easier to agree
with me
something you may find it a little bit
easier to agree with me
on is that black will not be able to
really improve his position
so easily these next nine moves in fact
by black
are basically passing moves
the pieces are just kind of shuffling
the structure changes not at all because
there isn't a good way to you know i'm
talking about pawn breaks for white if
we try and
look at from black's perspective how
does black create a pawn break that's
going to help his position
doesn't exist
there's no pawn move here that's helping
black out
okay so black has to take this
sit and wait approach which is just
a recipe for you know you're just ready
to lose the game if you just have the
sit and wait
wait approach white is slowly making
improving moves black is just
you know working behind his structure
like this move right here
you know rook on e8 to f8
those are never those are never fun
moves to play
rook that's going from a closed file to
a closed file
same story here closed file to a close
file i mean is there any guarantee
that the e-file or the f-file
will be opened up there isn't you know
are those moves going to be justified
it's not clear it's unlikely
um it's much much easier for white to
play
i mean everything is really tipping in
white's favor here
king position rook position space
bishop paris uh potential pawn breaks
that's that's the big thing here
white has the ability to create a pawn
break and black has this
yeah i have to sit and wait so
we're seeing that with king to d8
just back and forth pawn break finally
hits
we have some tension it took us a while
we're at move 28 but here we are
if black continues to sit and weight
with let's say going back here
i mean here's one way i'm not a hundred
percent on this but
this looks pretty appealing to take on
h6 and maybe play
f5 right what's this doing well we're
creating more pawn breaks and this
bishop has an eye on the h6 square
that's looking pretty promising so
what is black's reply here he goes with
f5
and the reply here is g takes f on
poisson
uh there's a nice little tactical
sequence here that
my newest my newest friend pointed out
to me stockfish14
uh i'd like to share this one with you
this move right here c4 is actually
there and it seems on
you know at first glance well isn't that
dropping upon well
here's the follow-up bishop to b3
i should have pointed out sooner when f5
is played
yeah e6 is a bit more vulnerable
one less defender around for e6 and
white is
with this variation keying in on this
point
the threat here is c5 and what is it not
doing
hitting the bishop cutting the defense
of the knight and adding additional fuel
to the pawn on e6
there really is not a good solution here
for black
i'm not even sure what to suggest if you
back up
trying to get out of this threat well
that's going to drop e6
is there any other try here there's c5
these two are hit
a computer's pointing out some knight
move
into d3
you can move the rook and then this is
still a threat
these ideas are a threat it's a big
problem
for team black still okay
the approach here by carlson isn't one
to you know
you don't really have to calculate that
kind of variation you could still take
this
you know controlled approach to the
position
he takes on f6 his focus is on doing
something on the king's side
creating some target potentially on h6
takes on f6 plays f5 an additional pawn
break
i was pointing out that the rooks are
helped once the pawn breaks are in but
so too
is uh this great positive this bishop
pair
so lines are opening up white is the
side benefiting because of these breaks
and now the g pawn is a target
we have the rook backing off and
this next move here i believe it took
about
six seconds to play this last move king
to g4
and you know you have to quickly
calculate uh a couple lines here you
have to know that
uh you're not going to get hurt after
pawn captures pawn
it may seem appealing right ah you're in
check i'm gonna get your unprotected
rook but
white would be able to meet this move
which was not played in the game he
would be able to meet that move with
captures and a check right back at black
and if rook takes bishop first there
would be this in-between move
and only then the capture of the rook
white
is up the exchange in this position or
after that variation
so there is no capture on f5 let's see
how this one ended up finishing
we have e5
another break with f6 pulling away the
defender of h6
if this guy is a runner uh this knight
is
not going to have a fun time tracking
him down
a knight has to work overtime to track
down a past rook pawn
okay bishop f5 check
knight e6 white takes that pawn
gets out of the way of the passer
and this knight isn't a pin on e6 so
like it's out of that but now we just
have a couple more moves
after chopping away on e5
white can actually play what move here
we're just a couple moves away from the
end of this game how does carlson finish
this one
forcing his opponent to resign in just a
couple moves feel free to pause the
video
okay here we go rook takes bishop
and after pawn takes rook rook takes
knight and black says i've had enough
throws in the towel at this stage no
hope here
for black if he takes the rook these
guys are too much
black king is out out of position even
if it was in a better position he would
still be losing this is
uh completely winning for white let's
let's put on some moves if
let's say this is how it continued rook
trying to get behind the pawn
marches and we can have white following
with something like that
bishop g5 preparing to cut the rook off
and
we're just two steps away from promotion
land
but it goes no further after rook takes
knight this game is over
alexa 81 resigns and with that we have
carlson
setting a new highest blitz rating ever
again just one of
three records he ended up setting for
this event so
again this was a game i only intended to
share i thought it would just be fun and
yeah somewhat surprised that i i
took something away from this 3-0 game i
guess that's what's
possible when the the champ the doctor
ends up playing
in these events still things to learn
from these brief games
anyhow i hope you maybe took a thing or
two away from this one
feel free as usual to leave any feedback
in the comments section below
hope you're having a great day and i'll
catch you in the next video
that's all for now take care bye
you